[Music]
oh
everyone thank you for joining us for
the 2020 canadian country music award
nomination
announcement i'm sheryl hickey the host
of et canada
now we've all had to make some
adjustments during the global health
crisis
and the ccmas are really no exception
but i am
very happy to announce that the awards
will air on
sunday september 27th at 9 00 p.m and an
all new format
right here on global so get your cowboy
boots ready
saddle up for what i am sure will be an
incredibly exciting show see my dogs are
even excited so what happens when you're
at home now yesterday
we announced this year's fan choice
nominee on et canada and i'm excited to
welcome
this year's fan choice nominee and last
year's big ccma winner to neil towns to
neil
how are you doing i'm doing so good so
happy to see you cheryl thanks for
having me
it is so good to see you so last year
you took home
four awards i still can't believe that's
real life or really
i bet well let's see if we can make some
more dreams come true
right here right now why don't you kick
things off
this is so exciting i've never got to
read out nominations before i said
all art we have for rising star
to neil arts matt lang
tyler joe miller emily reed
and sons of daughters
there you go oh all right the nominees
for songwriters of the year
are good old bad days skip black aaron
goodman matt nolan performing act
aaron goodbye i do too brad
rempel ben stennis jenna walker stuart
walker
performing act the wreck logs no trucks
son
jeff copeland tim hicks bruce wallace
performing act
tim hicks these days mackenzie porter
jordan sat
parker welling performing at mackenzie
porter
and jersey on the wall i'm just asking
tina parole gordy sampson to neil towns
performing act
tenerife that's so crazy oh my gosh
wow what a great day
[Music]
okay next we have group or duo of the
year
hi valley hunter brothers
james barker band the wreck laws
and the washboard union
okay the nominees for interactive artist
or group of the year
are dan davidson lindsay
l aaron goodman nice horse
and daniel pence
cool
[Music]
ding okay for single of the year
we have count the ways jade eagleson
drop dallas smith keep it simple
james barker band single man
high valley and whiskey in the tea cup
dean brody
all right the nominees for female artist
of the year are
lindsay owl jess moscaluk
megan patrick mackenzie porter
and to neil pound
keep this happening wow the nominations
aren't even fully announced so far
how are you feeling right now i'm crazy
that is so cool wow what an exciting
thing
now let's check in with my friend and
colleague graeme o'neill he's our
digital reporter at ut canada and graham
i understand that you have a special
guest with you to
announce the rest of the nominee thanks
cheryl yeah i'm here with canadian
country superstar
and this has a nice ring to it fan
choice nominee
dean brody how's it going dude i'm good
man how are you doing
yeah this is a good day for you already
already two nominations including fan
choice
how you feeling right now i feel great
man like
you know any year that we get nominated
is like a huge thing we're only halfway
through
the nominations so we're gonna get to
some more categories here okay
okay okay all right so here are the
nominees for male
artist of the year they are jade
eagleson
brett kissel dallas smith
tabe and some guy named deanne
brudy i'm not sure what i'm saying right
now steve brodie
[Music]
congratulations now they're not
questioning thank you that's amazing man
but what a good company to be in it's
great company it sure is
all right you're up next the nominees
for roots album of the year
are everbound washboard union
fingers crossed jj shiplet
kelsey kulik kelsey kulik
love wins kelly prescott and the other
way
donovan woods
[Music]
okay the nominees for album of the year
are
love heartbreak and everything in
between to nail arts
now or never brett kissel singles only
james barker band
wild as me megan patrick and
i feel like i have a broken record here
black sheep dean brody
no way man
i'll move here that's awesome dude i
didn't know that that would happen this
year
this is a little bit overwhelming right
that's great i'll take it
okay so your next category is video of
the year the nominees for video of the
year are
country thunder by washboard union
drink about me brett kissel jersey on
the wall
i'm just asking to neil towns no truck
on tim fix and silver lining
hunter brothers that's a great lineup
too wow it's a great list of nominees
okay last but not least the nominees for
entertainer of the year
the anonymities are brett kissel the
reclaws
dallas smith it's neil towns
and the one and only dean brody
five nominations so for dean brody yes
you got fan
choice album of the year mail artist of
the year single of the year
entertainer of the year how does that
feel man
it feels great man it it feels amazing
now you got to celebrate a bit yeah so a
bit yeah so the rundown yes you got five
brett kissel got five as well uh leading
the pack of neil towns with six
nominations
and then dallas smith james barker band
and the reclaws all got four nominations
so
an amazing lineup well thanks for
watching everyone and don't forget to
tune in on sunday september 27th at 9pm
on global
for the 2020 canadian country music
[Music]
[Applause]
awards
[Music]
you